[Music]
we work there they're there they're
everywhere no you imp them away from me
oh well I will I won't do it Sybil I
hate Sybil I hate her who are you I can
do anything I can do anything I want to
do anything is I think one other term I
take my shoes off like that like that in
like that and I had one other chair like
that like that I guess good stuff
flower girls
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to episode 23 of
the 13 o'clock 23 already 23 already
almost six months all we should probably
do something special like when we get to
a year okay we do that I don't know what
we're so much yeah little tool pick or
something out it'll be it'll be kind of
cool I guess yeah let's see what we got
to do first first thing we want to do we
want to give a shout out to project
Entertainment Network again
and encourage everyone to go and give to
their patreon yeah you get free stuff
you get free stuff you get buttons you
get a you know stickers yeah postcards
and beer koozies beer who can see
finally got around to getting some of
our own shirt yeah because remember all
those shirts that I'm always trying to
make you guys buy at the end ok so I
designed them and we have not seen them
on actual shirts yet no I finally got a
grill was it grill named sure liberal
making sure it hasn't arrived yet it
takes a long time for the elves to make
them how long ago was that replace that
order it wasn't that long ago yeah was
not only going to go okay so we'll let
you know how that how they look on the
actual shirt yeah Mabel again the
hydro-zone yes that would be I will put
them up on the condom website I although
the quality should be real good it
better be yeah they were expensive I
like the design well thank you yeah all
right so anyway with that out of the way
we are now getting to our topic
civil yes yeah Cybil and this is kind of
this was actually recommended by a
listener and it's funny because when it
was recommended we had just been talking
about about the simple case like a
couple days before I was like duh why I
think is doing a show on well there's a
new movie out by M night with his
national Amedeo so you Shama lemon
ding-dong out what Shamblin it's his
neighbor I guess so yeah yeah I always
call shamble I'm a big dog did you run
back with Nutley yeah and that one seems
to be about multiple personality
disorder but you never know there might
be a twist I'm sure there's going to be
yeah the M night shamalamadingdong twist
yeah
lucky does trailer man I really liked
what was that one unbreakable I loved
own breakable and I yeah like though I
liked The Sixth Sense and that was about
it all right but well back to civil and
I can remember suitable back when I was
a kid my babysitter talking about civil
about seven she's right about 13 14 you
know and she'd be talking to her friends
and they were scared of this this was
almost kind of like a made-for-tv horror
movie back of the day you know they
didn't really know much about multiple
personality and disorder it wasn't look
like on par with for the time at the
psyche on par with the Exorcist in the
omen and you know yeah am evil horror
prisoners Rosemary's Baby that kind of
stuff yeah they had a lot of cultural
impacts and I only now that you
mentioned it has never occurred to me
before but all of those movies that came
out like in the early seventies weight
sixties early seventies well with demon
possession and stuff like that this is
kind of like the psychiatric equivalent
of it yeah demon possession of multiple
personality had a lot in common
they do and I definitely not that never
occurred to banshee I said that and I
was like wow maybe that's why it was
such for some reason whatever was going
on in the culture at the time in
possession was like a big thing right
and like you're not who you think you
are there are other people inside of you
and yeah like them a lot of parallels
yeah which is kind of a frightening
thought so I can see there was something
culturally going on at nighttime where
and remember all the stuff about the
abuse you know hold your water and all
that kind of stuff I could remember the
girls you know oh yeah the older women
that surrounded me all your hot baby
centers all my hot 13 a 14 year old
babysitter ha ha ha he was seven it's
okay they were older women there are
older women and my favorite one was Kim
and was a little candy and she looked
just like Princess Leia oh she was just
like my this way that was his earliest
crush this is your first love I got
pictures of her my mom took pictures of
all of us at one time I remember I came
across a few years back she lives just
like Frizzles away that's hilarious but
it was funny she didn't look like an
older woman less are
Buchan yeah what yeah I don't know yeah
where's yours she was 13 you're like you
know I feel weird anyways okay so yeah
so it's kind of cool that it's like that
someone suggested this because Sybil the
book came out of 1973 when I was one
yeah this is a convoluted case we have
to like keep this nailed down and
structured so what what we're going to
talk about is the book the movie and
then the actual case is that the best
way to keep it organized yeah cuz you
know how we do we kind of go off on
Kenya and that's fun I like do and that
was like real muddy real quick but
otherwise I'll just be all over the
place right I'll get shrekt out and have
to turn it off so this is because I get
overwhelmed I like what was I talking
about I don't know all my notes are
openin [ __ ] yeah but um the book came
out in 1973 when I was one now I read it
god I don't remember how old I was when
I was probably a kid cuz I was like I
was all into that kind of [ __ ] when I
was a kid now I just go to the library
and I get all the adult books out that I
wasn't supposed to be reading and so
this likes fascinated me for a long time
now for those of you who are not as old
as we are and you know don't remember
like the huge cultural impact that this
had in the 70s the book actually sold
what like six million copies like before
government and that was before the TV
movie was made I'm sure it sold many
more after that so you know but it made
us quite a bit money and the TV movie
came out was shown in 1976
and it had Sally Field in it and Joanne
Woodward played the doctor and that was
like huge like everybody [ __ ] saw that
everybody saw that and everybody was
talking about it and actually I think
Sally Field wanted Emmy for that from
that if I'm not mistaken but the gist of
a story is and civil is based on a real
person obviously but that was not her
name it was a pseudonym and I'll get
into that later like that later they
found out who the real person was the
book was written by its Laura reader
Schreiber she was a journalist and she
collaborated with the doctor dr.
Cornelia Wilbur that was her real name
and with G patient Sybil Sybil Isabel
Dorsett was the name they gave her for
the books but that was not her name now
initially here was
what happened in the book and also to an
extent in the TV movie and they've
remade the TV movie 2 in 2007 with
Jessica Lange as a doctor who is
actually pretty good I found it on
YouTube yesterday illegally so uh so if
you want to watch it it's on there so
the original suppose probably impossible
to find
I found clips of it I couldn't find the
whole thing right um so my trying to
find Salem's Lot yeah we like that one
yeah we try to find and I even checked
that place in a DVD only and I was like
oh my god
yeah we recommend potatoes a lot for
made-for-tv movie that was an awesome
movie because it was better than I
remembered it it was a lot better than I
liked to him as well yeah we were
talking about that yesterday she can't
just Sandra you know yeah another
tangent surprise that's what big was fun
okay so okay so what happened here
this girl Sybil she was a college
student at the time and she initially
sought therapy because she was having a
social anxiety emotional breakdown she
had been in college for two years and
she was actually doing fine before that
but evidently she started having these
all these emotional problems and most
significantly
she complained that she was having
episodes of missing time okay she was
saying you know sometimes I'll wake up
and it's five days later and I don't
know what I've been doing for the past I
know UFOs reported no alien abduction
none of that right no this Betty and
Barney no [ __ ] and I looked like no
picked up yet we got anal probes and all
well check yeah okay yeah yeah no no
UFOs although I'm surprised that that
wasn't you know suggested by anybody
that kinda doesn't he'll jump on with a
book oh yeah it was actually all just
alien abduction hey maybe I should write
it oh [ __ ] no I just blew it I didn't
say that I didn't say it okay so anyway
so she's having episodes of missing time
she's saying I'm in my apartment and I
look in the closet and there's dresses
in there that are not my style that I
don't remember by you know people are
coming up and talking to me like they
know me I don't know who they are and
all this other kind stuff which was
obviously very upsetting for her but as
it would be now initially reportedly
like I said there's
portes there's all kind of [ __ ] about
this on the way if you want to look it
up it's kind of like he said she said
yes this is a very convoluted yet kind
of saying it's like all kind of
controversy about the diagnosis and all
this other kind of stuff so I'm just
kind of going by the general consensus
of reports now at first dr. Wilbur
thought that she might have
schizophrenia right which was not
terribly weird because her mother
reportedly had schizophrenia and you
know it tends to run in families so she
consulted with another doctor named dr.
Herbert Spiegel and Spiegel put her
under hypnosis and stuff like that now
as dr. Wilbur worked with Sybil
evidently it started to come to light
that Sybil has dissociated and had 16
different personalities that weren't
terribly aware of each other and that
Sybil the main personality was not aware
of at all
so when you say main personality you're
talking about like suppose that her
normal her normal personality to you
what you know it's kind of hard to sort
out because it's like if you have that
many personalities which one is going to
do and which one is yet but generally
they're saying you know civil Isabelle
Dorsett her pseudonym that was her given
name and that was her main personality
now apparently this personality went and
sought treatment but she did not
remember all these other personalities
apparently they were doing [ __ ] without
her knowledge okay but she didn't like I
said she didn't know that that's all she
knew was I woke up and it was five days
later I woke up and I was in another
city and I didn't know how I got there
[ __ ] like that so now there is some
controversy over whether dr. Wilbur it
says that it says that she hypnotized
her but I don't know if that's the case
however she did give her sodium
pentathol right which as we mentioned on
our show on The Devil's breath is
generally if you use kind of a truth
serum type of thing and she was you know
apparently
talking to her when she was under the
influence of sodium pentathol and as
that started to happen she began to
manifest all these different
personalities now the main personality
and the one who knew about all the other
ones was named Victoria and she was
French she said she had been born in
Paris that she had loving middle-class
parents and so forth she spoke with a
French accent she could speak some
rudimentary branch of evidently and she
was kind of like the boss personality
like she was very self-assured she knew
all of the other personalities she knew
their names and she knew what they were
for so apparently this was kind of like
the regulating coordinator now in the
book is he a ringmaster the ringmaster I
guess you could say now in the original
book and I believe in the original 1976
movie Vicky was only 12 years old now in
the remake with Jessica Lange she was 18
so she was kind of like a flirtatious
French girl and she was the one that
would tell the doctor about what all the
other personalities were up to so and
she was the one that kind of took care
of everything
but as they're kind of psycho
psychotherapeutic relationship continued
dr. Wilbur began to suspect that there
had been some kind of very traumatic
abuse in her childhood that had caused
her to dissociate into all these other
personalities this is where it gets good
yeah because some of the personalities
seem to remember things that symbol
herself did not remember her because
evidently Sybil was saying because the
abuse they think it came at the hands of
her mother according to these person
according to the personalities and
apparently the mother had done all kinds
of horrible things devil when she was a
little girl this is what I remember
this is what I remember well this was
the mode I think whenever what most
people remember like from the book in
the movie because it was really kind of
sorted and out there yeah like all the
stuff that her mother would do to her
right give us an example
well it was kind of a thing like well I
remember specifically was the ice-water
enemas yeah she would um the mother with
high Sybil's lengths to a broomstick
yeah and then you know stick a tube up
her butt and then shoot ice water upper
yelling some like me she would like tie
her underneath the piano she made while
she played really loud and she would
like not let her pee yeah make she
Walter water
yes that was kind of the famous out a
famous quote well everyone I did miss
covered and the mom was just generally a
[ __ ] I mean yeah you know speaking up
she would take a dump in people's bushes
she'd run around another mom in the
neighborhood yeah it really the mom
would run around in the middle of the
night peeking in people's windows with
civil with her and then she's like
pinchelow
people's on people's yards and
everything it was bizarre
yeah it really dissolved and also there
were also like some other now apparently
there had been open I forgot about the
lesbian horrible that's why we needed
girls that's what I was just going to
say there was apparently some sexual
abuse as well evidently the mother she
was she was actually called Hattie in
the book and the movie but her real name
was Martha she would rape Sybil with
various household implements yeah and
also yeah lesbian orgies with TNA to
keep teenage girls around the
neighborhood that Sybil was apparently
seeing I don't know why and you know
things of that nature I mean some of
this stuff seemed I was almost going to
say breathable that's probably another
word Madonna the model plausible threat
some of the stuff seemed a little off
the rails now how old was Sybil
supposedly when this was going okay now
this was different ages because they
kind of figured out that like all her
personalities kind of corresponding with
ages at which particularly horrible
things happen to her like one of
to one of the personalities I believe
they was Ruthie was a baby okay and she
was like pre verbal okay so whenever she
went into that personality you know
obviously the doctor could really
communicate with her because she was
just like make baby noises and but some
of them were you know three years old I
think right six
but when all this running around the
neighborhood and the lesbian orgies
house how old was just a civil supposed
to be at that time does anybody know now
it's too big
yes okay so she couldn't give times and
dates during and when this right right
now in the book and the original movie
and in the remake um the doctor works
with Sybil for about eleven years they
develop a very close friendship and as
it goes on she is able to hypnotize
Sybil and convince all of the
personalities to progress in age to the
same age as Sybil is because most of
them are younger and once she does that
you know it takes several years but
eventually she's able to integrate all
these different all of the different
personalities into you know one person
out and now in the book more or less how
old is she when she's able to do this in
a greater mall she I thirty yeah I think
she was in her thirties at that point
okay maybe four he's actually because I
think I I think she was like in her 30s
when she first started I remember Craig
she was born in like nineteen twenty
nine nineteen twenty three to twenty
three I think what he was you know up
there and age yeah yeah she wasn't like
a kid right yeah but um the thing is
here's where it gets kind of murky
because many years later when they
finally found out who the real person
was that civil was based on there's kind
of a lot of there's a lot of controversy
about how much of her story was true if
it was completely fraudulent if it was
simply exaggerated if her symptoms were
encouraged by the therapist
how much of the abuse was real because
it kind of ties in and I think we talked
about this a little bit on episode 2
about the satanic panic because we
talked about the whole repressed memory
thing that got very very big in the 80s
where a lot of therapists were like
suggesting write like satanic ritual
abuse and other kinds of like really
horrific kinds of abuse to their patient
and they don't know if a lot of it
really happened or not or if it was just
suggestible people being given these
false memories well in a satanic
actually we did you know we demonstrated
that a lot of what was reported could
not have happened yeah was inaudible you
cannot flush a little kid down a toilet
and then have that little kid arrive
alive in an underground torture chamber
yeah and and Chuck Norris was not
beating that little kid right there okay
that we hell up and since we're not
flying away the balloons right you know
there was not yeah so obviously and like
I said this is where it gets a little
tricky because yes child abuse is a
horrible problem yes a lot of children
are abused some of them quite horrific
Lee and grotesquely but you know because
of the satanic panic and what happened
in that in like the McMartin preschool
case and stuff like that where these
kids were coming up with this [ __ ] that
was just crazy that was just impossible
right so now it's kind of swung in the
way other direction where it's like the
crazier your abuses the more people are
being like [ __ ] nothing happening
right yes and I'm not sure that's the
case here now what I should say is that
you know after Sybil was identified as
Shirley R del Mason that's her real name
she's dead now but um she was identified
before she died as as being Sybil
now her mother reportedly was gives up
red X okay neighbors have reported that
she was weird right that she did creep
around at night look at people's windows
not so much about this pooping okay but
um you know one does the woman that
lives across the dresser I know it's
awful it's all
the woman who lived across through this
day she would creep around at night and
look in people's windows which is kind
of weird enough and that she was kind of
which like right not a roll happy woman
right and other neighbors and a couple
of civils teachers you know have said
that you know the parents were very
strict
they were seventh-day adventists and you
know they would hold her hand really
tight or they wouldn't let her do
anything and right stuff like that were
they strict sure right were they abusive
be hard to say right might have been now
Sybil's father you know said no he
obviously he defended his wife right um
but you know he would do that so there's
no way of knowing whether the worst of
the abuse has happened
okay however you're there no witnesses
yeah there were no direct witnesses and
they couldn't find any teenage girls but
they were had been involved in these
orgies or anything like that right so
you know the thing is Sybil was
obviously an emotionally disturbed woman
she had problems right did the problems
come from this like unbelievably baroque
abuse can't really say right could have
happened
I mean none of the stuff she said was
impossible it was just probably pretty
unlawful right but she might have been
abused you know just in a kind of
run-of-the-mill what a quote kind of way
you know the goodness all Bloods being
awarded in the wood and holding your
water all right yeah well that could
have been to that yeah so anyway so the
real woman
Shirley O'Dell Mason and she was born in
1923 and apparently um quite brilliant a
reportedly IQ of 170 for which is you
know very high very talented artist very
talented musician um although later on
some of her personalities could play
piano and some of them couldn't okay and
another thing that kind of came out
later I think they went into this in the
book and also in the movie a little bit
that most of her personalities could
paint
when you saw the pictures that she would
be one of the influence they were kind
of different styles okay you know I mean
which was kind of a weird thing but when
the book and the movie came out and was
such a big cultural phenomenon it seemed
like now previously to the book coming
out there had only been between 75 and
200 cases of multiple personality
disorder diagnosed in the world right
now after that came out in the ensuing
decades let me guess a increased yes
next financially okay and it became a
fad yeah and you know tellingly the
diagnosis only really increased in North
America right you know we weren't where
it was really where it was released so
whether that was a case of therapists
now saying oh now we recognize the
symptoms of this disease so we can
diagnose it more easily or whether it
was kind of a thing where we're just
going to take this other you know mental
disorder kind of glommit onto this
because it's sad --is-- right and I
really don't think that that controversy
has really been resolved to anyone's
satisfaction even for this day to me it
sounds a lot like the alien abduction
thing where you brought money under
hypnosis and they remember all this all
this stuff that happened to them that
probably didn't happen
yeah although there are a few of the
alien abduction cases that are kind of
compelling they're interesting but it
kind of money of that yeah
and like I said it kind of reminds me of
that whole solve everything I'm Noah
Jenna kind of like Michelle remembers
that work and all that of that net
identities yeah that was a very big
thing so it's kind of hard to tease
apart now there have been accusations by
different doctors that Cornelia Wilbur
the doctor the therapist who was
treating Sybil either purposely or sort
of accidentally suggested these
personalities suggested multiple
personality disorder he
either in order to I mean either in
order to sell books or because she
really thought that that's what was
wrong with the woman right you know I
don't want to impune the woman's
reputation she's dead too um you know
she wasn't a quack by any stretch of the
imagination she won a lot of awards and
accolades and stuff in her field and but
there have been some accusations that
she and civil and flora Schreiber who
wrote the book kind of collaborated and
you know had this kind of plan as a
business plan a business plan that they
were going to make like a cultural thing
we're going to have t-shirts we're going
to write a musical we're going to have a
board game yeah we're going to have that
kind of stuff so there is some evidence
that they kind of wanted it to be
multiple personality disorder because it
was sexy yeah we can get more into that
in the second half the show yeah because
the more you look into this case the
more you find out that there was there
was some what's a good way to put it
shenanigan there was some shenanigans
with this case not allegedly alleged
chanel legit [ __ ] I think it's a mixture
I think a case is actually a mixture we
should probably take a break now
yeah we're almost at the halfway yet and
then we can get more into it we didn't
Emma crap this up you know yeah because
it's an interesting case but there's a
lot of stuff that was you know it was
kind of in between the lines yeah this
is it's a long gray area with some gray
areas okay so we're gonna take a break
and we will be back in just a minute
I'm captain Valentin I'm learning every
person German project Entertainment
Network program with vodka I regret it
till the time learning a lesson and
ammachi
super cheap pro wrestling in the hot
spot
three interviews putting up is coming
any superstars that are stable no shoots
wow it works you can only hear the
amount of project entertainment it's
like a variable whoever do subculture
courses in clothing is our favorite
store for unusual clothing shoes and
accessories they offer a wide selection
of men's and women's clothing at great
prices so culture also offers the cool
selection of shoes and accessories
steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in jacksonville
florida just off i-95 the net rope
casting you on the podcast that lets
lore and heavy metal products with a
common connection brought you my house
talking jump log max max
smoking hot Hades and ours real Mordecai
featuring interviews and more with the
stars Medellin
the necrochasm mozzies on project and
excitement Network
[Music]
[Music]
you
there are terrors real and imaginary and
I write about them all paranormal
nonfiction or fiction Rochdale deterred
iron the mammoth mountain associated
monster read minute
supply of Rosella weather go to WWJD
AFRICOM or search Amazon for the Jenny
Ashford author page ok and we're back
yes so when we left we were just talking
about the kind of controversy about the
diagnosis and you know what what they
may have stood to gain from making it
multiple personality disorder
now I don't think anyone anywhere is
saying that Sybil didn't have some type
of mental disorder she clearly did at
least get the brain yeah and actually I
mean reading about her I sort of feel
bad for her because I don't know if she
was really I'm not saying she wasn't a
willing participant if this was kind of
you know an exaggerated kind of thing to
sell books but the way she was it almost
seems like she went along because she
thought that's what the doctor wanted
right and that's what some that's what
other doctors have said later including
dr. Spiegel who also he didn't really
treat her but he saw her a bunch of
times and apparently he hypnotized her
also now dr. Spiegel said that he did
not think that Sybil had multiple
personalities in the classic sense he
thought that what was happening was that
she was you know maybe she had some
repressed memories maybe she had some
abuse in her past and she had some kind
of PTSD type of reaction where she was
walling things off but he thought what
was happening was that the dr. wall
Sybil was on sodium pentathol one or
when she was under hypnosis that the
doctor was suggesting to her that these
different memories of these different
aspects of her personality were a
separate person and we're not giving
them names thereby creating thereby
creating a separate personality
maybe there wasn't one there before that
was that was dr. Spiegel take on it he
just thought that Sybil was probably and
emotionally you know kind of emotionally
unstable kind of person and she was real
suggestible he said it was very easy to
hypnotize her which is common with
people with these types of disorders and
that maybe she was kind of taking like
for example and I think they even
mentioned this in the book in the movie
that she had a child personality named
Peggy that was sort of the one that took
on all the anger allegedly as what her
mother had done to her
because the real Sybil apparently was
not allowed to express her anger or her
hatred for her mother because of their
religion because of what have you so
apparently was all glommed off onto this
peggy personality okay so what dr.
Seibel was would suggest was going on
there that maybe Sybil the main
personality had all of this repressed
anger which was still her right but that
dr. Wilbur was calling it Peggy right so
in other words as the therapy continued
more and more personalities would emerge
I think the the records of the therapy
demonstrated that right that some of
these personalities didn't have names at
first yeah
that's how I remember them ended up
having names I think there was one one
of the ones too emerged later was called
the blonde she didn't have a name and I
don't know if they put that in the movie
but that was in the book but and I think
that was the personality that ended up
becoming the dominant personality and
when they're all integrated again right
but you know it's like I said this is so
this is so like hard to tease apart
because evidently you know the doctor I
don't think dr. Spiegel said he didn't
think that dr. Wilbur was doing this to
harm Sybil or that he was doing it on
purpose that she was doing out on
purpose right he just thought that
because Sybil was so suggestible and so
eager
please I wanted to make dr. Wilbur happy
you know they were friends they work
together for such a long time and so he
thought that maybe dr. wood she was just
doing what does she thought dr. Wilbur
wants and just create more personnel
which is create more personality now the
more kind of cynical Creek critics
allege that flora Schreiber is a woman
who wrote the book and dr. Cornelia
Wilbur were fully aware that Sybil did
not really have multiple personality
disorder but that the publisher of the
book that they had already worked out
the contract with said no it's got to be
about multiple personality disorder
because it's kind of a sexy disorder is
kind of coming out you know so kind of
long and will sell a lot of books if
it's that so there was something to gain
financially right by having her half or
least claimed to have multiple
personality disorder yeah because of the
book right okay and muddying the waters
is the fact that apparently Sybil had
written a letter in which she said that
she did not have multiple personality
disorder and that she was kind of she
said that she knew something was wrong
with her but that she was essentially
making it up because that's what she
thought dr. Wilbur wanted right
however now I should not do that right
yeah I should note that this letter was
put in the original book okay Flora's
Robert did put it in the book okay so
he's trying to hide you know they didn't
try to hide it they said Sybil did say
that in a letter however how they spun
it was that she could well she said
Sybil the main personality she had been
at a 2-day tube when that letter was
written so one of the other
personalities wrote it and Sybil didn't
remember okay and this other personality
was apparently fighting against the
therapy all right and I think they
showed this in the movie too because
apparently at first the personalities
quote-unquote did not want to be
integrated right so they were fighting
because a lot of them didn't know about
each other so this statement of I don't
have multiple personality disorder was
actually could possibly been given by
and all
meant personality right I'm just saying
that because she wanted to get out of
therapy or didn't want to be integrated
with the other personalities or wherever
that's why this is such an awkward kind
of case like such a controversial case
because there's really no way of knowing
right I mean because this woman was was
kind of you know emotionally unstable
and stuff like that so can you take
anything she said yeah I don't have
multiple personalities they could really
you can't really like yeah you take
another grin a song yeah because it's
like you know she could just one of the
other personalities could be saying that
she could just be saying that to get out
of you know whatever like the next
breakthrough was going to be because it
required or whatever you know she could
just be a denial right so like I'm
saying be you know to their credit they
didn't um they didn't hide that letter
now evidently like I said the two of
them dr. Webber and Sybil are surely
based on issues was a real name but I'm
just going to keep collar said well
because it's less confusing but they had
a very very close relationship now
allegedly at some point when Sybil was
you know younger and she was first
starting to undergo the therapy she
didn't have a job and so dr. Wilmer paid
her rent and bought her clothes and ones
like that so like I said there might
have been some financial you know some
financial gain going on there because
she didn't she didn't have another way
to support herself and I should note
also that they stayed friends like
apparently when out Sybil ended up
having to move out of her hometown
because after the book came out even
though details have been changed even
though her name of an age even the names
of all her alternate personalities had
been changed people figured out people
figured out it was because it was a
small town she was from a small town in
Minnesota Minnesota called dodge center
and you know they knew exactly here that
book was about and so it was a little
awkward so she had to move away now it
seemed like for the rest of her life
she lived real close to dr. Wilmer so
she's like you know move closer and
stuff like that now she did get a job
later she was an art teacher she taught
art she taught art of the call at a
community college and apparently she was
a very good teacher
very good art
did you know high IQ yeah very talented
woman but it kind of like there came a
point when she got older where she
couldn't make any decisions without her
doctor's input and things like that so
there might have been some kind of weird
like symbioses going on with the two of
them but not real sure and like I said
you know the book in the movie proceeds
were all divided three ways between the
doctor be civil and the author and is
the kind of the weird thing too is that
later on in life
Sybil actually she got breast cancer
yeah in the 1990 1990 and she did not
like doctors not like hospital so she
denied as she said she didn't want
treatment Wow so now the cancer went
into remission for a while but then a
couple years after that dr. Wilbur got
Parkinson's disease and Sybil moved into
her house to take care of her Wow uh-huh
so you know so dr. Wilbur got dying of
Parkinson's disease and then you know
Shirley Mason aka well she died of
breast cancer much later because she
denied treatment right and it was kind
of now friends of hers when she died she
died in 1998 and you know they said that
she was quite happy when she'd never
married she never had children she
always kind of lived alone kind of
reclusive you know she had cats play in
her garden or whatever and oddly even
though you know her evidently her
family's faith had been kind of a big
bone of contention that they were real
strict and stuff like that she stayed a
seventh-day adventists until she died so
like I said maybe not now she had
severed all ties with her hometown she
did talk to her family anymore I
shouldn't talk to her old friends
anymore so you know there might have
been some shift behind that too one of
the weird things is struggling by the
state so there was merchandising in
Brawl oh yeah was that they were trying
to sell t-shirts yeah they actually
there is some evidence that the three
women had started and this was even
before the book came out okay that they
had they had registered civil
incorporated a civil incorporate yeah
and that that was going to be like books
movies they were going to do like a
board game
we're going to do like more game yeah
which I was like how do you make a
multiple partner working up some wild
[ __ ] there yeah there's something
suspicious about that that's what I
think he asked me there's something
suspicious about that yeah weird now
like I said it should be noted like how
how much of this was the doctor just
being a cynical cash grabber as saying
oh here's somebody I can mold into
somebody with multiple personnel
because like I said you know after all
the stuff about repressed memory
syndrome is false memory center it's
very easy it turns out to implant false
memories into people's head especially
if you put them like under hypnosis or
you put them under into influence of
some drug ursin like that and you keep
telling them is this happening over over
eventually they'll remember it like it
really happens they'll even start adding
details of their own and that's very
very easy to do yes I mean before I
think I think many years ago people used
to think oh your memory was like you
know like a video tape you could just
play it back memory is not like that at
all well ok so what what do you think
was really wrong with her now here's the
thing many others did there was a book
that came out by Debbie Mason and this
came out in the late 90s I believe it
was called civil exposed and her theory
was she went through a lot of dr.
Siegal's papers and you know various
other things and she kind of came to the
conclusion that that one dr. Wilbur was
kind of exploiting Sybil like I was
molding her into somebody she thought
that civil might have had pernicious
anemia of all things why yeah
because apparently it's some kind of
blood disorder and I guess back in the
day it used to manifest like the
symptoms that it that it would present
with were sometimes misidentified as
like very psychiatric disorders now
according to the book Sybil expose when
they treated Sybil with like you know
liver supplements and things like that
like she actually would get better like
her psychiatric symptoms would go away
allegedly I don't you know I
that's I've really only read that in a
couple of places like in that one book
so you know whether it was anemia or
whether it was something else I tend to
think like as a non psychiatrist I tend
to think that it was some type of could
have been schizophrenia could have just
been you know borderline personality
disorder could have been something like
that because I mean initially the
symptoms that she presented with and I
should note too that multiple
personality disorder if not they don't
call it that anymore since I believe the
DSM for which I think came out of 2000
actually might have been earlier than
that they might have changed it in 1980
but they actually call it dissociative
identity disorder now and it's still a
very controversial because some
psychiatrists don't even think it exists
right they think that it's you know that
it's being confused for other things
because it's very rare to see the type
of thing that was presented at least in
the film where this woman is just like
switching personalities like on a dime
you know we're like she's in the office
and she like oh now I'm this person
album baby now listen it is very very
very rare right and most of the symptoms
like I said the most significant sense
symptoms is missing time when you come
in and you claim hey is five five days
don't remember what I did the last five
days and you know but that is also a
symptom of one schizophrenia also
borderline personality disorder so I
think nowadays though there is no
consensus I think nowadays dissociative
identity disorder is kind of seen as a
subset of borderline personality
disorder okay because some of the
manifestations are the same so I don't
think people are you know I don't think
it's like a separate diagnosis necessary
from disorder and yeah I went to this
row because it does seem like most of
the people that are diagnosed with it
it's kind of just a handful of
psychiatrists that are
diagnosing repealer you know I mean it's
not and there's not even really any
agreed-upon symptoms are like yeah
that's what that is because it's kind of
a very awkward kind of thing to diagnose
you know kids it manifests in such a
strange way and also I think in the in
the newest DSM they also have something
called possession trance forcing like
that time so they're kind of tying it
together like you were saying about
movies earlier right they're kind of
tying it together with people to think
they're possessed by demons or think
they're being taken over by other
creatures or other identities and it
should be noted too that I just read
this on the Wikipedia page about
dissociative identity soar it's really
long but it's kind of interesting that
some people that have presented with
this alleged disorder you know not only
do they come out with like normal people
they said most of the time most of their
identities are just other regular people
but sometimes you get ones that are
animals now or celebrities or
mythological creatures or mythological
people he likes it he said celebrities
are reminded that program that that
program we saw last night was a guy who
thought he was Madonna
oh yeah John my second addiction I don't
know watching my face to develop and
that guy wanted to be Madonna yeah and
not just dressed up as Madonna he wanted
even on Donna it was bad he was already
at the end I think he throws jnanis em
away but um so like I said kind of I
don't like wish to because like I said
most of the people involved are dead but
you know Sybil yeah I gotta get real
never really know and you'll never
really know whether this was a real
disorder or whether it was something
that was just kind of you know finagled
into that to make a particular narrative
yeah because you have to say that like I
said just like we talked about in the
satanic panic show we talked about a
little bit Amityville Horror Show - it
seemed like a cultural you know whole
milieu of the time was for some reason
everybody was super into demon
possession and like I'm taken over by
other I date that was a very big yeah it
was weird bad then and it kind of went
way you know with this yes and it went
into the 80s so I can see how the
kind of identity switching type of thing
would appeal right to people from that
time period I definitely think she was
mentally ill yeah yeah I don't think
anyone is disputing what I think her
doctors were trying to help her
yeah I don't I don't think like I know
that some journalists and some other
doctors have said maybe that there was
some malicious but I don't think that I
don't think she but I do also think that
the job is a priority for the doctors to
have this be a multiple personality case
for money and that money would also help
civil yeah and I think the multiple
personality disorder thing that she had
it from what from what I can tell was
intermittent sometimes yeah it was
something to do to get better sort of
just go away yeah but I kind of agree
with you I think it was probably more
like schizophrenia yeah it might have
rather you're what they call a
borderline personality storyline
personalities work yeah yeah I generally
do think that I don't think dr. Wilbur
was necessarily trying to exploit her I
think she was trying to help her but it
might have been a case where here's a
woman that's presenting with these kind
of strange unusual symptoms Ron and you
know multiple personality disorder at
the time was very very rarely diagnosed
Ron so you can see how a doctor at the
time might be encouraged maybe not even
consciously right to sort of push her in
that direction
right so she could have like a kind of
unusual case study right to sort of base
her career upon right and you know like
I said the woman had a good career
before that but she's still to this day
best known for this case for this case
right and I should note that also later
on she was actually instrumental in
getting I believe his name was Billy
Milligan but he was one of the first
people to the first male to get off on
an insanity defense for multiple
personality disorder she was like
instrumental in his defense Wow so that
was like the first time
so she was kind of like the go-to person
for this for multiple personality
disorder and she got known for that
which you know you can see how the you
know the especially if you're a doctor
you don't want to just you don't want
just boring old goal doctor you want
your celebrity doc yeah you kinda want
to be a celebrity and you're like here's
a woman that has he weird symptoms and I
can kind of push it in that direction
this is a this is something that hardly
ever happens
yeah and it's very rare you know it's
just like not like normal bipolars or
different John you know this is sexy she
has she doesn't remember she she's
summer four personalities one of them
was a baby two of them were boys and
stuff like that and it was just kind of
weird sorted yeah and I mean I should
note this was kind of funny I think they
went into this a movie too but she had
two male personalities one of them was a
Sid and I can remember those name but um
there were teenage boys and evidently
when she was one of these boys she
really thought or she said that when she
grew up she was going to grow a penis
where she would be able to put a baby in
a girl that's what one of the male
personality said trying to be able to
pee standing up yeah so but apparently
and when I saw that when I saw the movie
like the the boy said would get really
annoyed when the doctor would be like
but you're not a boy you don't have a
penis or not you know they're drawing
he'd get really upset about that as
funny but apparently you know the boy
was he was a carpenter just like her
real father in there so they were all
obviously fragmented you know fragmented
aspects of her own personality he was
just kind of personifying then or the
doctor was doing it and getting them
names but you know like I said it's kind
of it's kind of a sad case and I feel
like I feel like civil herself I don't
know she's necessarily a hundred percent
the victim but um you know she obviously
had a lot of problems and I mean the
doctor did help her I didn't end up
having like a relatively normal life
later on I mean she painted she was a
teacher she was doing stuff like that so
you know did it really hurt her I
yeah they didn't make some money off
they did make some money off of it
actually when dr. Wilbur died she left
her 25 grand oh you know which was night
and so not a hoax no it did happen might
have been slightly a misdiagnosis there
may have mimicked clean up a little bit
yeah but still an interesting kid and
the abuse we don't really know how much
does that happen that might have been
exaggerated kind of like flushing kids
down the toilet yeah go back and listen
to a panic panic oh that's actually what
that's still one of my favorite shows
yes I just I just because we lived
through that and I just remember so much
about it yeah we have a fun hummus on
that one you know some guy was saying
that yeah man I lived through it too
graduated today how would you guys are
talking yeah people our age we
remembered you so like I said this is
kind of like a there's probably like why
I'm so fascinated why I've always been
so fascinated this case is almost like
the same thing because I've always been
bad at a nightmare I've always been
fascinated with false memory syndrome
and that's whole thing about people
being able to connect freaks me out it
freaks me out but people could put you
under hypnosis or give you give you a
drug or something like that and then
suggest all the [ __ ] and then you
remember it like it really happened that
is [ __ ] freaky yeah today I mean you
know and probably most people when they
grew up you think that your memory is
like pretty good like oh I remember this
happen you just pledged that ever
they're not proven that your memory is
really bad it is very bad yeah and it's
reconstructive every time you think back
to an event you're adding and changing
it all right so it's never ii remember
how how cool thing remember how cool
certain toys used to look without your
kids from back in the seventies yeah
and then if you look that up on google
let's see what that toy actually look
like it's nothing like you remember it
mag man I think Wayne hahaha yeah well
everything's cool your kids yeah you're
a kid everything's cool that's the only
thing that sucks about well it's not the
only thing but doesn't what they respect
about getting older is like nothing's
cool anymore go back and look at some
old music videos a lot of them don't
look anything like you remember well
yeah and that's kind of the thing is
that was my big thing when I was a kid
was good you know MTV 30 was nine and I
was like
we do it for men on run and I still have
such fond memories of all the videos and
now you can see them you're going to go
on YouTube and you're like wow yeah that
looks like it was made for like a buck
98 and look at their hair wait why did
we think that was cool as a dime why why
did I think that that outfit looks so
cool you look at it now like a seagull
[ __ ] I'm still kind of like it there is
is there but we don't have enough yeah
okay so we're getting close to the end
of the show hope you guys enjoy one is
here rambling I hope yeah we're gonna
ramble well yeah that's how we do these
different entertainment purposes and
just you know there's a lot about this
case if you're interested in it you can
go look at it yeah we and read the book
the book is excellent even if the abuse
part was [ __ ] is still like
delicious and I kind of exactly kind of
hard to do a show on this because there
was so much about it
yeah and a lot of it is hearsay yeah and
like I said it's something like they're
all dead so you're never going to really
sort never gonna know and and you know
the character one of the characteristics
of mental illness is that it's
subjective you know you're never going
to know what your problem really was or
whether you know so anyway I guess we'll
reppin it every okay so um it's the end
of the show so I'm going to remind you
again go to project Entertainment
Network on patreon and give them some
money and get some free stuff it's
really cool also go to zazzle.com plus
there can rock and buy some of our
t-shirts eventually I'll add more I
promise and we'll tell will tell you
what they look like when we get ours
yeah and if you're on youtube please
share your favorite shows with some of
your friends we can get the subs up and
we got a little bit of we got we got a
show for everybody yeah and if you have
any recommendations or shows you want us
to do but like I said this one was a
recommendation and yeah leave it in the
comments as a live show yeah leaving the
show moves to accommodate yes we want
there we might uh we're not promising
anything
we'll see look is that some good
recommendations so far yeah yeah you get
the curling we're going to get to curl
we don't yeah because that's been
recommended by a couple people so we're
going to do that we're going to do that
but um so anyways that will do it for
this episode of 13 o'clock and please
like us on Facebook and like us on
Twitter
not to mention that and that'll do it we
will see you next Tuesday and if we bye
bye
[Music]